hey guys welcome back to dlm men's
lifestyle today is another video request
and the question we got is this Daniel
please make a video on how to stop
procrastinating and be more productive
well let's not waste any more time let's
get to it
so why is it a problem when you are
procrastinating
because that is the enemy of success and
think about it when you procrastinate
you do nothing to move forward in life
you basically just waste time precious
time and time goes by so fast Michael
alsular said the bad news is time flies
the good news is you are the pilot so
how good a pilot are you and where are
you steering your life towards a pilot
who is procrastinating is kind of
steering himself to nowhere he has no
direction at all so let me give you five
tips to stop procrastination and to be
more productive
number one
[Music]
self-discipline a good place to start to
stop procrastinating is self-discipline
and self-discipline starts with the
little things like making your bed if
you can't even make your bed in the
morning it shows that your mind and your
way of doing things is already wrong
because if you don't do the small things
right like making your bed it shows that
you are lazy and you don't have
self-discipline guys you need to have
some self-respect
Hebrews 12 11 says for the moment all
discipline seems painful rather than
pleasant but later it yields the
peaceful fruit of righteousness to those
who have been trained by it
you need to have self-discipline in all
areas of your life and that includes
over your emotions that's the difference
between you and an animal an animal an
animal is led by is the emotions but you
have self-control
so let me ask you this and be honest
do you have control over your emotions
or
are you a slave to your emotions are you
controlled by your emotions
this is important because if you control
them your emotions then you will not
give in to procrastinating when you feel
like it your emotions when your emotions
pushes you and say ah don't be lazy oh I
don't feel like doing this that's the
moment you push yourself through
self-control
and you control your emotions and say
I'm not going to be lazy I want to
achieve success so I'm going to do this
create a daily routine set up a schedule
for every day of the week because if you
do it this way if you write it down then
you know what must be done to achieve
success to reach your goals and if you
write them down and if you follow that
routine you will also stay consistent
and you need a daily plan because if you
don't plan ahead what do I always say
then you plan to fail so start writing
it down mine goes like this I wake up I
have breakfast and coffee
then I work out while listening to a
sermon or praying while I work out
next shower
then I check my schedule for the day and
plan ahead
at 9 30 am I have a meeting with my team
from 10 30 to 12 I work
12 to 12 30 I have a short break and eat
something
1pm work on dlm until 5 PM then from 5
PM to 9pm I leave open to work on my
side projects or spend time with my
family
you need to make specific time for
specific things that are important
scheduled priorities for example
if you don't do what needs to be done
today when you know this is important
and I should actually do this if you
don't do it then you know it's going to
carry on to tomorrow to the next day and
make the next day even harder never
leave something to tomorrow that you can
do today and if you're young struggling
with this
write down your to-do list and then take
your phone and set your alarms for
everything you need to do as a reminder
then when your alarms go off do what you
need to do even if you don't feel like
it just do it until it becomes a habit
until it becomes normal no one told me
this when I was younger I had to teach
myself to do this self-control and you
can do it too
be healthy now
for some of you wait and hear me out
before you make any assumptions you only
have one body in life this is all you
get right you don't get another one and
with time it wears and tears when your
body does not get the nutrients it needs
or the exercises it needs you cannot
function at a hundred percent
and many people only function at fifty
percent because they do not live a
healthy lifestyle
and if you can only operate at a fifty
percent man it is so much easier to
procrastinate because you don't feel
like operating or doing anything you
already feel 50 lower energy and you
don't want to do anything
that's why it is important to have a
healthy balanced lifestyle there's a
quote that says the best investment you
can ever make in life is your health
you know the older I get the more I
realize just how true this is
I mean think about it why do you do this
to yourself
you keep eating unhealthy sleeping late
and then you need to depend on energy
drinks or coffee to just fight your own
emotions of feeling lazy and tired all
the time which of course leads to
procrastination
control yourself and give your body the
fuel it needs to be able to operate
function at your best at a hundred
percent because then you'll be able to
be the best man that you can be at all
times
find your purpose if you don't have any
purpose in life you're like a a boat on
the ocean without an engine or a sail
tossed around by the wind and the waves
now your purpose and your passion
usually goes hand in hand but the
problem comes in when there are many
things that you are passionate about so
how do you find your purpose then how do
you choose
while you pray about it the Bible says
in Ephesians 2 verse 10 for we are his
worksmanship created in Christ Jesus for
good works which God prepared beforehand
that we should walk in them
let me share something with you I did
not know what I wanted to become in life
at high school people kept telling me
Daniel what are you going to do after
high school and I just said I don't know
because I didn't know I thought maybe
I'll become an electrician so that's the
subject that I chose at school but after
that I didn't like it so even at 16 I
started to do waitering at a restaurant
then after school I went to England I
became a Salesman and I prayed to God
but he was silent all those years
then while doing psychology I started to
do modeling to pay for my studies and
that went on for a long time
then I finished my degree in Psychology
and I still did not feel 100 peace with
it I felt like man yeah it's okay but
it's I don't feel like it's this is what
I wanted to do so I continued to pray to
God and ask them what is my purpose
and God was silent for many years
but then in China
of all places you showed me that I
needed to teach the truth to All Nations
and all people
and I started to study Theology and it
led me to do videos online
and man when I started to do videos I
started to do that while I did modeling
and I almost didn't sleep and let me
tell you when you know your purpose that
leaves no room for procrastinating
because you know what you're working
towards
so find your purpose pray to God and
don't give up because his timing is
different from our timing he's just
waiting for the right moment keep on
praying keep on knocking keep on asking
and he will show you the way
be unselfish you know when you just work
on things for yourself being selfish you
know because you want certain things in
life
it's so much easier to procrastinate
but now if you do things where it
influences other people
their lives their responsibility is
bigger because now it's not just about
you it's bigger than yourself
and now that pushes you to work harder
instead of procrastinating because if
you don't push yourself if you don't do
anything and if you're going to
procrastinate that's not going to bring
any value or make a difference in the
lives of other people it might actually
be negative Philippians 2 verse 3 says
do nothing from selfish ambition or
conceit but in humility count others
more significant than yourselves Let
each of you look not only to his own
interests but also to the interests of
others
imagine if everyone lived this way the
world that we live in right now would be
a totally different place it will almost
be like heaven on Earth if people lived
unselfishly let me tell you there's no
greater feeling that you can get and to
bring value to other people's lives you
know there's many people who try to fix
themselves who got emotional problems
but instead of trying to fix yourself
start to help other people to fix them
because while you do it you might come
to realize that that is actually the
cure to heal yourself as well Acts 20
verse 35 says in all things I have shown
you that by working hard in this way we
must help the weak and remember the
words of the Lord Jesus how he himself
said it is more blessed to give than to
receive
what's up of man do you want to be a man
who lives selfishly for his own
pleasures and Desires in this short
temporary world and you gain all
material things and then you die
you take none of it with you
when you lose your soul for all eternity
do you want to be this guy or do you
want to be the guy
who is not selfish
who helped other people who is a man who
lives righteously and when you die you
leave behind a legacy and you gain
eternal life
the choice is yours
I hope you choose right life is short
so don't waste yours cheers guys